[Applause]
anyway
uh you also know what happened with
cardi right i'm getting back with it
yeah i never understand this man i think
we probably talked about the podcast
before but like
and i know there's a comic that had a
joke about it i'm not sure who it is but
like if you're a girl that says all men
cheat
you can't really break up with a guy for
cheating on you that's true
because the replacement guy according to
you
is also going to cheat because you say
all men cheat
yeah so you're putting this you're
putting yourself in a situation
where you got to accept cheating because
that's all there
is right i mean you could be
perturbed by it but if you want to live
your life
with a man and your belief is that all
men cheat
you're gonna get cheated on so when it
happens why are you so shocked and
whoever you get you ain't gay
you're gonna get cheated on yes any man
you get with can cheat on you because
all men cheat except you could get a
girl
if you don't want to get cheated on if
that's the number one cause now i don't
believe all men sheep because i know i
don't cheat
okay i've cheated not on my girl but
i've cheated in the past
you know what i'm saying so maybe they
do i don't [ __ ] know you know maybe
he always was out here dry humping girls
back in the day
that's why they got assless chaps
exclusive dry hair
behind girls in texas just rubbing up on
them so their butt cheeks went out of
the way
but faithfully faithfully though back in
the day
back in the day i'm saying back in the
day right
what i said akash would make assless
chaps he'd be grinding up on you on the
club
you walk home what cheeks just hanging
out your jeans what they do in dallas
bro
that's what they came up with that's
what i just said mark if you were
listening
so point is can
you be mad at cardi if she has that
belief
no because no girl wants a man to cheat
no
i'm not saying any girl wants her man to
cheat and i don't think all girls have
this belief system i think there's a lot
of girls that believe that guys will be
faithful but they also believe that guys
have cheated right
and i think there's guys that believe
that girls will cheat a lot of times
people are unhappy in relationships they
cheat
right but if you're one of these girls
who's like yo men and [ __ ] they all
cheat
and you decide to be in a relationship
with a man
you can't break up with him for cheating
that makes no sense
especially divorce because where are you
gonna go you married this guy
now you get divorced get with another
man who's poorer and cheats now you get
cheated on my
poor guy don't you really get cheated on
by a rich guy
well i mean that's what she did she took
him back because he bought her [ __ ]
rolls royce or phantom or some [ __ ] like
that
what is that she said it's not why
[Applause]
but that was a big ass rock that he gave
to yeah
yeah he gave her an infinity stone now
[Applause]
though like she's definitely going to
take probably he she took officer back
before cheating
it's just like winning so if you're off
so when do you stop
so here's the question if you're offset
and you know she's going to take you
back
what reason are you going to stop
cheating but that's you took me back
so what is it you cheat five times and
then you don't take me back
well here's the thing the inflation gift
cost is
rapid rising you know i mean the first
time he cheated on no [ __ ] rolls
royce
this time as a rolls royce next time
it's the [ __ ] kobe ring
then it's a hot like it's gonna the cost
just keeps going up you think who they
cheat on also affects the price no
i don't really i don't so if you just
cheat on like some random group yeah
if you make them look we know as if you
look make them look embarrassed
that's all they're embarrassed every
time you cheat
that's gonna they're just gonna be
embarrassed but maybe it's all about
perception because publicly you get this
rolls royce so now you look
better whereas before and he looks a
little like simply or whatever the word
is and before
you look like [ __ ] you got cheated on
you get disrespected but now you're
getting rolls royce in front of
everybody
and now your perception's a little bit
saved maybe it's just how am i perceived
by people i don't want that to be
i think that matters i 100 agree with
you i think that that's huge
and for everybody yeah especially the
girl but it's just a weird thing like
what reason do you have not to cheat if
you want to cheat in the future
if she's taking you back a few times now
i'm i'm not against taking someone back
for cheating though because like
i think a lot of people don't realize a
lot of people that judge that not taking
someone back for cheating
are in like high school relationships
they're not adults that have a child
mm-hmm like you guys are different you
know it's different different
it's different like one night where you
[ __ ] up
is gonna dictate the rest of your
child's life
yeah it's also the nature of the
cheating if you're in like a 10-year
affair with some other random person
boom if you get your dick sucked in the
back of a pizza hut
i don't think that that's something
that's maybe like completely breakupable
now if my girl did that obviously i
would break up with her because she
could die somewhere but that's fine
and i'll steal the child i will steal
the child it'll be amber alert you'll
see
andrew schultz amber alert amber alert
uber uber amber alert real talk that's
the bias
uber xl little more room for my kid that
you tried to take away from me my
[ __ ] dixon pizza hut
[Laughter]
how y'all forgive us for cheating you
know real time
i'm going through it right now that's
crazy because men it's
you better be different hormonally whole
relationship real talk
girls are like i don't want you to be in
a whole other relationship and have a
whole thing if it was just a one-time
you know little hook-up i could maybe
forgive that but if you had another
family on the side i could never forget
that
i hope you got a family on the side if
you cheat on me yeah cause then i get
free time
that's perfect you just found a silver
lining but not only do i get free time
at least you love this [ __ ] you
sucking his dick
yeah it's not you lust him imagine you
lusted a dude you're just looking at
some guy you don't even know now you
sucking his dick
[Music]
i'll throw up just thinking about that
nah but if as a dude what if you cheat
i'm starting to dislike my girl she
didn't even do nothing
this is like when she's literally
building up a story of my girl doing
that and she even do it and i don't like
her now